ever get stuck while writing an email
finding the right words or stuck on that
article you can't find the final words
for well to get rid of this writer's
block a myriad of AI tools help you
achieve your targets we are now at a
time when artificial intelligence tends
to do many jobs better and more
efficiently due to the lack of human
error it's not just content creation AI
can find use in a ton of scenarios let
us go through some of the best AI tools
available today that can boost your
productivity at number 10 you have magic
eraser by Magic Studio Magic Eraser
removes unwanted images from your
pictures using artificial intelligence
it can decipher the backgrounds and
remove unnecessary elements out of a
picture beat unwanted Birds on a
landscape shots or branding on social
media posts select the element to be
removed using the Eraser and let the
Tool Work its magic next at number 9 we
have the thing translator this tool
allows users to point their camera at an
object and hear the translation in a
different language using the cloud
Vision API and the translate API of
Google the translator serves as a godson
for foreign Travelers or just people
trying to learn a new language with both
the Google API set to develop up even
more over time expect the thing
translator to become more helpful than
ever at number 8 we have tab 9. tab 9
analyzes and recommends your next blocks
of code based on the context and syntax
get lengthy accurate and creative code
completions to become a more efficient
developer cabinet's AI completions may
be executed on a developer's laptop
behind a firewall or even on the cloud
it recommends code completions based on
your coding Tendencies it supports the
most common languages such as JavaScript
Python and typescript and even more
Niche languages such as rust go and Bash
irrespective of what your Tech stack
looks like tab 9 will boost your speed
at number 7 we have Trevor AI travel AI
is a daily planning program that
leverages intelligent time blocking to
connect your list of activities and
calendar it supports integration and
two-way sync with services like Google
Calendar and todoist taking control of
how you spend your time based on
schedules and time frames it helps plan
your habits and work life to create a
streamlined approach to your day using
artificial intelligence this helps helps
you focus on the individual task rather
than worrying about cramming your busy
schedule into the entire day at number 6
we have deep Nostalgia deep Nostalgia is
an online tool developed by a company
called myheritage and can animate faces
from old pictures my Heritage license
this unique technology for animating
photographs from did which is a firm
specializing in video reconstruction
using deep learning myheritage uses
technology to animate the faces in Old
images and generate high quality
lifelike video footage the tool Works
equally well for black and white
pictures and photographs taken in color
so needless to say the results are
pretty astonishing and can be quite
moving in many cases number five on our
list goes to durable durable helps
create sample websites in under 30
seconds for people starting a new
business or who are generally not well
versed in web development just choose
the type of business you are running and
the name of your company to get sample
designs made immediately from spaces
assigned to customer reviews to buttons
allotted for social media profiles
durables ensures the websites match the
latest trends in web development you can
restyle the colors and headings or sign
up to further customize the website
based on your requirements at number 4
we have Jasper with the growth of AI
everything it's only a matter of time
until AI is utilized to produce content
for your blog social networks websites
and other platforms Jasper AI formerly
known as Jarvis is a low cost service
that generates original materials such
as blog entries for you it's simple
enough for almost anyone to use all you
have to do is enter general information
about what you want to address and the
AI will do the rest providing over 50
templates Jasper can handle a
significant amount of the heavy lifting
for topics that are often written about
the AI can provide a solid foundation of
information to which you can
subsequently add your own unique Insight
number three on our list goes to Tetra
with Tetra you don't have to note down
your minutes of meeting every day Tetra
dials into your calls and essentially
takes notes for you allowing you to
focus on the discussion now and remember
all of it later authentic speech
recognition has yet to reach the level
where it can function as a via able
alternative Jetta also has a notes
viewer with each audio byte synced with
the notes this level of detail allows
you to focus on the meetings discussion
without making individual notes
throughout the call at number 2 we have
the dolly 2. the latest groundbreaking
text to picture generator from openai is
called to only do it enables users to
produce visuals in response to text cues
users can use this generator to
transform the imaginative thoughts into
lifelike Graphics if you scroll through
Twitter and look for the hashtag dolly2
you will be greeted with many images and
artworks shared by many people based on
different topics from Victorian era
style pictures of aliens to just plain
portrait style images Dolly 2 has all
its bases covered regarding variety the
AI is taught by a deep learning how to
make text to image associations which
the model later uses to recreate the
relevant images finally we have chat GPT
at number one openai has unveiled chat
GPT a powerful new chatbot that uses an
improved version of its AI technology to
Converse in plain English while you has
existed for a while this model has
reached a critical point it is
beneficial for a broad range of
activities from developing software to
generating company ideas to composing a
wedding toast while prior iterations of
the program could potentially execute
these tasks the output quality was far
worse than that of a typical person
since its debut Twitter has been
bombarded with people using it for
unusual and bizarre purposes such as
creating weight loss strategies and
children's novels and providing
instructions on retrieving a peanut
butter sandwich from a VCR it seems chat
GPT will serve as an important Monument
for artificial intelligence to be
welcomed in the consumer sphere so that
wraps up our video on the top 10 AI
tools for 2023 if you have any other
crazy AI tools please share your
comments and your thoughts subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this
and thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here